[Music]
in brain backup news submitted by
Hendrick hey wait like Vietnamese honcho
and sounds like a Harry Potter kid named
Hendrick Kendrick oh down the kind of
wands startup is pitching a mind
uploading service that is 100% fatal
that she's like alter carbon in a couple
days and might as well yeah that seems
to be like the Pete the first people are
they're gonna they should have done this
for Stephen Hawking yeah why don't you
just even Hawkins did someone tell me
what's been Hawkins Hawking's it depends
on how it's pronounced maybe download
your brain do what yeah this is dr.
Stephen Hawking should done for Stephen
now you're kind of what about Stephen
Hawkins yeah let's go let's go walking
yeah walking Civic Stephen Joaquin
it Stephen Joaquin what happened -
estefania Joaquin Esteban walking
somewhere up there he's going and I like
and I like that mm-hm right back at you
buddy
I'm like how even in heaven he still has
a severe he's like you've got to be
kidding me
gods like I got to keep you humble I got
to keep you humble man you're so smart
angel II still in a wheelchair in a
smile he has a genuine smile of Stephen
Hawking the company that was founded by
an MIT graduate has called neck tome
neck Tom neck dome and it's the way I
pronounce it okay
there's really mech Tom Beck to me neck
though still sounds what I don't know
anyway moving on oh no they asked the
question what if we could back up your
mind and so what they're saying is that
they believe that in the future there'll
be
able to download the mind into a
computer from this process of them
embalming a living brain with their
special chemical mix by embalming the
brain it will 100% kill the person and
that having this done to them sure can
implant it and reset it on another
person's brain or transferred it to a
robot no the thing with this it's
already happening to us do mm-hmm
what if our brains are already in the
juice you know I'm saying you know what
in the juice know if our brains are
already in the juice right now and to
keep from just sitting there and being a
brain that nobody wants to talk to
because your ancestors passed on we have
this [ __ ] reality that we're all in I
always think that exactly the
holographic projection theory that's the
alternate universe wanting to change the
life hasn't been disproven yet still I
believe it sometimes sometimes mm-hmm I
just go through different phases because
of his Christian faith he has trouble I
go hmm
sometimes it's Jesus and then sometimes
when I don't need help I go maybe it's
science but it's usually when I'm scared
it's Jesus yeah you know what do you
guys believe it okay so you've already
said sometimes even I don't believe in
[ __ ] no I just would never have whatever
luring us out lately lately I've been
into meditation a lot right so I'm like
I don't need this [ __ ] Christian [ __ ]
like I just I need to just work on my
inner self and that's how I just need to
do you know and then and then sometimes
when I when I'm alone and I'm like is
that a [ __ ] ghost Jesus where you at
Jesus yeah yo help me that's and now I
start singing [ __ ] Bible hymns and
[ __ ] but that all these demons go away
it's so interesting to like like I
specifically remember a friend in high
school that almost got somebody thought
he got somebody pregnant right because
she basically was [ __ ] around things
showing this fake [ __ ] that he he was
like praying you're like ugh god what
did I [ __ ] I specifically remember him
saying [ __ ] God he doesn't exist but
this [ __ ] got on one knee to
stick to one man the brainwashing is
wrong I love it any when I want to be
all telogen is [ __ ] I just like believe
in [ __ ] alternate reality what do you
believe - same system
renessa should I believe don't read it
just could say from your heart I'm
looking down I don't know I really
believe she believes in the chupacabra
no like I believe in the universe I
believe that the whole universe is just
like one like the universe is God and
like whatever we die it just gets
recycled into the universe yeah go on
ahead cuz that's not Jesus gonna hell we
all Greece's going to hell yeah yeah
right here yeah that's it that's why I
like I'll speak to God in my mind but
the God in mind like I do believe like
we're all we there is like some type of
power but I feel I believe that the
power is the entire if just lost 20 is
20 Cain Scott followed right sub count
live sub count going to God to me first
it's a hipster in a robe know for sure
I'm gonna get judged for my beliefs but
you don't even have to say that I
actually believe that as well exactly
you just said I legit do yeah yeah well
God is the universe like an energy thing
like it's [ __ ] like the universe like
I don't know it's weird to say like I
believe in the universities like well no
[ __ ] the universe's there but it's so
it's a weird thing to say right but it's
like I I like I like the idea that when
we die we go to the source whatever that
is
maybe it's a [ __ ] computer game I
think so yeah I think I think this is a
simulated reality for whatever our soul
is to play this game yeah we need to
keep it occupied we need this game that
is got levels of difficulty I also think
that when you start the game I'm not
even kidding I think this is a
fascinating theory like you start the
game right and it's like okay well
choose your difficulty level right and
it's like okay well I'll choose like
it's like you can have an appearance
like so you can be better looking but
then you you suffer in this area and
this area it's like oh you're gonna be
good looking but you want to have bad
skin but then you want to be tall but
then you want to have like a medium
sized dick or whatever you know I mean
that's like well like you living it you
starting to throw a rule country or
first of all country yeah right you're
hot as hell yeah but in a starving
country yeah do you believe in karma I
believe in karma I don't believe in
karma at all I don't call it karma for
me it's kind of what you guys are wind
energy what wind energy
I just call it balance universe like I
believe in karma is itself because all
of the biggest youtubers and
talented youtubers that I know are the
saddest people that I know butts or the
smallest youtubers that's true that's
true
I just think that it's just all the luck
of the draw that's awful you just think
this is everything that's happening is
one big accident I think things just
happened the way they happen like I
don't I don't have to believe in karma
that's something because you're a bad
person back there's a lot of bad people
great awesome things happen to them it's
just like it is what it is you know what
I mean but then that's all perspective
because you're seeing it as good they
might be like well I only have 200 shoes
this is all perspective like everyone I
know who's made it is a youtuber so it's
of my only my only like Ally yeah that's
it
yeah both see that's us kind of having
to find a reason for them to be unhappy
who knows maybe they are you know maybe
I just don't care it like that's what it
is
once I started carrying about with
somebody else another [ __ ] their Karma I
don't give a [ __ ] anymore he stresses me
out I don't worry about my [ __ ] self
yeah it's like I think he was going
through this phase and he was younger
cuz his dad is really religious I told
him God ain't real
he better quit with that [ __ ] we
were gonna go hiking and [ __ ] and he was
like Jesus said God this I was like look
that's brainwashing none of that talking
my car do you tell me is real though yet
Thompson's room yeah that's just like I
I just I didn't want to impose like my
beliefs on hunt and I didn't want him to
feel like oh my mom doesn't believe in
God because I I do in a sense but like I
said my God is the universe right so
then I was just telling him that like
you know just just think outside the box
like always question whatever
information you receive like it doesn't
necessarily you know you're not to take
it for face value and and then like so
Kasey and I started to like just ask
questions as to like what he thinks
about a certain beliefs and so the more
he like thought about it then he started
saying things like well I don't know
maybe there is a God or maybe maybe the
gut that we know is kind of different
I'm like okay so you're you're starting
to think for yourself now so I believe
in the MMA method so everything the
ancients have come up with there's no
perfect one method right and I feel like
different culture
they value and emphasize something else
that the other one doesn't so an Asian
culture I think they emphasize a lot
more on just acceptance like accepting
as things are and they don't use much
logic but what they do use is ways to
figure out the flow of emotions and
stuff like that which is totally
different concept to Western culture
which is more logic and reason based
because how Western culture evolved is
through like Greek and Roman and then so
forth where it's a lot of like the
Western philosophy is let's figure out
the truth through science right and then
they have Christianity too but it's
always like we were having this
conversation this morning with Bart me
and Bart we're talking about how
Europeans kind of evolved with the whole
like begging of God like God please this
and that so then you're looking for
external things to solve your problems
we're in Buddhism you're learning you're
looking internally and and like
meditating and just trying to figure out
things and letting it be yeah I like
Buddhism so it's yeah it's two different
schools of thought but I think there's
no one way it's both pretty good because
one gets you to strive and improve
through like figuring out the truth and
then the other one is like let me just
accept things that's the way they are I
want to see a picture of the universe
and I want to see it's both one way
they're both pretty good Joe Jitsu Gio
do you believe in are you what it's with
you I know I was with you guys
okay well always been like the universe
balances itself out and some people call
that karma some of the people call it
God I'm just like I mean I believe it
okay I'm a [ __ ] waves crashing on the
rocks deed where it is what it is [ __ ]
happens right
could you grew up Buddhist I think so I
think I probably Buddhist ideals where
it's just [ __ ] happens yeah and
sometimes they're good sometimes were
bad and you could take good things as
good things or sometimes like good
things happen to good people II think
it's about it's all perspective I'm a
Christian Buddhist and I just just think
like [ __ ] happens this make the best out
of what happened yeah you sound like a
guy who's just about to go surfing you
know
[ __ ] happens bro get laid get [ __ ] get
paid all right I'll see you out there
that's beautiful today though it's kind
of like I can't sit here and question
why something always happens yeah we
were talking about this conversation
with me my friend Khalif we're like you
know what sometimes like when things are
scenario when your life is very like
uncertain you kind of hate being alone
because you get stuck with your thoughts
and then I was going to get some tackles
right and this guy to look like Flavor
Flav with neon green glasses so the
homeless guy comes up and he's like want
me to draw your picture for like 15 or
25 bucks I'll say first of all extortion
get away from me
second of all he goes hey it was okay to
be alone sometimes like you know what
god I'm trying to do this right now
completely ignored the sign I was like
is there you know I'm not dealing with
this okay like this is very creepy it's
just a little creepy you know I mean I
just want deal with it what if a guy
came up to you like in that way were you
having your own personal crisis and he's
like you know he's like he like takes a
dick out and he was like hello David I
am God like like do you feel like you're
having absolutely not he like almost
said verbatim what I was talking about
that day for up to three hours
I seriously and then in that he said
that one specific phrase he goes it's
okay to be alone sometimes you don't
have to worry about it he goes that's
the time that you're gonna grow the most
and I said well first of all you're
homeless you can't give me advice but I
give my head but you know what would you
say that to Jesus
yes I you got visited by God like hey
man maybe she know in real estate tears
laughing because I imagine him flying up
but because he's a drunken homeless man
he flew into the sign and crashed into
the tree he's not a perfect apostle yeah
started getting upset and I was like you
know what God why would you said this
man you know meet like why how come
everybody else has this great story of
like their grandmother coming to them
you need polish right David you want a
guy in a suit yeah I want the briefcase
maybe an old 80 cell phone and he's like
hey hold on a sec David you should talk
to go
I had a guy that looked like Flavor Flav
with neon glasses that tried charged me
15 to 25 bucks for a stick fingers sure
that's true charity by the way when you
would say yes to that yeah
thank you Jesus without what god works
in mysterious ways
[Music]